So, keeping on the theme of a mental health day,
um, my husband and I have been doing a little dry patch,
a little sober journey, um,
for about, I wanna say six weeks now.
But one thing that we have been looking for are mocktails
and drinks with adaptogens and or other fun
side effects. So these kept popping up on my TikTok shop forever.
So I have heard so much about microdosing, um,
mushrooms and, of course,
you know, the green.
The green living.
So I decided to try these out because,
you know, a mom can get a little stressed, and I.
And people swear by this,
just for reference.
I'm, like,
very much a lightweight,
so I'll drink, like,
half of this and feel, like,
just kind of loosen the goose.
Also, always be responsible.
My husband is home,
so I'm not, like,
alone with my kids.
It's the end of the night,
and it's kind of replacing the glass of wine that we used to have.
Cheers.